after years of insisting on the
importance of in-person learning we
classical education people are suddenly
forced into the world of online learning
and our job now is educating students
remotely and advising their parents
about how to do this work that we're
used to doing so first of all that's
very hard we miss our students and we're
used to being them being there with them
in person every day and it's hard to see
the success it's hard to see you know
how we can be productive in this new
environment we need to acknowledge first
that no matter what we do for the rest
of this semester it's not going to be a
substitute for what was going to happen
and I think that's okay to acknowledge
the loss acknowledge that it's a shame
but then move on to figure out what we
can do to make the most of this new
situation this is an opportunity for us
to remember that parents are the primary
educators of their children it makes
sense that when something terrible is
going on kids go home to their families
that's a sign of what we have always
known we love our students as teachers
and we take care of them and we love
watching them grow up but we are not
their parents their parents are their
parents and this challenging situation
is a reminder of that that means that as
teachers our work now all of a sudden is
to help the parents figure out how to do
the work that we were going to do in the
classrooms and that's a beautiful thing
it's a beautiful thing for parents to
become more involved in their children's
education than they ever have been let's
talk about ways to keep classical
education going even when your students
aren't physically with you in the
classroom part of the reason that in
classical education we think that
in-person learning is so important is
that there's kind of a community in the
classroom and there's a community in the
school and we're afraid that that
community is going to be lost there are
a few things that you can do to
encourage community so for example if
you have older students middle school
and high school students you can do
things like zoom meetings you can do
things like phone calls where your
you have a number of students on the
line maybe a small group is better than
a large group but something so that that
conversation that you're used to in the
classroom can still go on the other
thing that I think we should remember as
teachers is that this is a time to keep
it simple first of all acknowledge what
will be lost focus instead on what you
can do what opportunities you have with
these new challenging circumstances and
as you think about what plans you had
for the rest of the semester
focus on the things that are most
important don't think about quantity
think about quality think about what you
as a teacher need your students to come
away with at the end of the unit or the
end of the semester or the end of the
week and use the means that you have
before you whether it's sending home a
packet or emailing students or using
zoom or using phone calls use all of
those avenues that you have to be very
focused with the student and the parent
about what exactly the meat of the
lesson was what was the most important
thing that you wanted them to learn and
then finally remember that your job as a
teacher is not merely to deliver content
that's not what classical education is
about it's not about filling the minds
of these students with a whole bunch of
information it's about helping them
become a full human being now that means
different things for different people
but ultimately what it means is helping
our students learn to practice the
virtues helping them develop broad
understanding in the liberal arts and
sciences and then ultimately helping
them become thinking people who are able
to choose right and wrong I think if you
keep that final mission in your mind
during these challenging times it will
help you direct all of your lessons in
the right direction thank you and good
luck
you